also breaking overnight after months of
political battles and a major piece of
president biden's ambitious domestic
agenda is moving forward the house
passed the president's 1.2 trillion
dollar infrastructure bill about three
months after it was approved in the
senate the measure paves the way for job
creation and the biggest federal upgrade
to the nation's roads bridges mass
transit and other projects in years the
vote was 228 to 206. 13 republicans
crossed party lines and supported the
bill while six progressive democrats
opposed it its passage comes with hopes
that congress will soon vote on the
president's sweeping social spending
plan christina rafini is at the white
house with the very latest christina
good morning
good morning michelle well in a
statement around 1am president biden
called passage of the infrastructure
measure a monumental step forward saying
it will create millions of jobs and make
the american economy more competitive
but after months of delay and democratic
infighting the passage is also a relief
not only for the white house but for
certain washington reporters who frankly
were almost completely out of
infrastructure puns
minutes before midnight the motion is
adopted progressive democrats finally
got on board we've always said we need
to get both bills done and tonight we
have an agreement that will get both
bills done
voting to pass the bipartisan
infrastructure bill after party leaders
promised the larger social spending plan
would get a vote no later than the week
of november 15th everybody expects
everything to happen just like that but
it is legislation and
we're very pleased that very strong vote
votes on both films 13 republicans voted
for the infrastructure measure which
passed the senate in august to vote on
something just because it hurts the
president it's not the right
lens
so i just tried to do the right thing
after months of delay democrats once
again found themselves deadlocked in
disagreement forcing president biden to
cancel his trip to delaware on friday
anyone who is up watching c-span at this
hour wonders what in the heck the house
is doing right now this time it was
moderates in the house withholding
support for the president's 1.75
trillion dollar build back better plan
until they see a cost analysis from the
congressional budget office
what's going on
we're working man the development
prompted house speaker nancy pelosi to
make a last-minute decision and move
forward with the 1.2 trillion dollar
bipartisan infrastructure plan on its
own have you talked to speaker policy
today i don't have any
calls to read out the white house had
hoped to end the week on a high note
following the positive news that more
than half a million jobs were added to
the u.s economy our economy is on the
move but rising consumer prices mean
many americans might not be feeling
quite so bullish about their buying
power
if your number one issue is the cost of
living
the number one priority should be seeing
congress pass these bills
now we're expecting president biden who
did stay in washington last night to
make remarks about the infrastructure
bill as well as a way forward on the
build back better plan say that three
times fast later this morning dana
i won't even try and by the way i do not
believe that you would have been out of
puns christina that's right
i might never it might be never thanks
thank you